A more sort of traditional or
i say fundamental computer vision method
of doing active sensing is what's
referred to as structured light.
So here's this stereo figure that you
might remember that we used before.
The idea was we had two cameras, right.
And there was some point out here and
that point would project, oops,
missed the line there,
okay that's better.
It would project to this point here,
it would project to that point there.
And because i knew which
two points they were,
i could figure out the triangulation,
alright.
Well, structured light says,
instead of having a camera over here,
I'm going to put a projector.
And what this projector is going to do
is, instead of having a sensor here that
notices where a point is, and remember
we had to go look for the point.
What we're going to do is we're going to
send the things out this way, right.
So we're going to send some particular,
think of just one point for
a minute, right.
And then in this camera over here,
we're going to see where does that
point show up on the image plane, and
then we can do the triangulation.
But instead of doing points,
what we actually do is we
project stripes of some sort.
In fact, sometimes this is
called a light striping, right.
And here it's shown with colors
that makes it real easy.
And the system of course, knows where
each of the colors lies on it's plane.
So then in the right image.
In the right camera, the only camera,
we see a picture that looks like this.
So, what you can see here is like when
these things are bent like this, okay.
As it comes closer to you, right.
So it comes over here,
it moves to the left and so
the line moves to the left there.
In fact, you can see that a little more
clearly in this image here, all right?
So we have a set of hands and
these are the light stripes
that are projected on them.
And actually this is observed
in just the right-hand camera.
And here what you're seeing
is a 3D reconstruction
of this surface based
upon that light strike.
So basically, by doing this light
striping, by projecting these
stripes out and then seeing them over
here, i can recover a full 3D model.
All right.
So that's one form of
projecting something out.